we've seen in previous videos that
photosynthesis can be broken down into
the light dependent reactions and the
calvin cycle and the light dependent
reactions is where we take light as an
input along with water and we'll see the
water is actually a source of electrons
and we can use that to store energy in
the form of atp and nadph and as a
byproduct we produce molecular oxygen
which is very important for us to
breathe and then that atp and that nadph
can be used in the calvin cycle along
with carbon dioxide to actually
synthesize sugar what we're going to
focus on in this video are the light
dependent reactions how does this
process right here work
and to help us think about this we are
going to zoom in
onto a thylakoid
membrane so this is a thylakoid right
over here sitting inside of the
chloroplast and if we zoom in on its
membrane we see it's a phospholipid
bilayer like many membranes that we see
in biology and at first glance that
might this might seem like a very
complex diagram and that's because it is
a complex diagram and you will often see
things like this in your biology
textbooks and it can be very
intimidating these these proteins and
molecules and complexes have very
complicated sounding names but the
general idea of what's going on is
you'll hopefully find a pretty
straightforward you have the energy from
light photons from light are going to
either directly or indirectly excite
electrons those excited electrons
they're in a high energy state and
they're going to be transferred from one
molecule to another
and they're going to go to lower energy
states that's what allows those
transfers to be spontaneous for them to
actually occur
they they they're going from a higher
energy state to a lower energy state the
electrons are getting more and more and
more comfortable and some of that energy
that's released as the electron goes
from a higher energy state to a lower
energy state is used to pump hydrogen
ions
hydrogen ions across the membrane from
the outside of the membrane in the
stroma to the inside of the membrane to
within the thylakoid lumen so you are
building so you're building a a hydrogen
ion
concentration gradient
concentration
gradient where you have a higher
concentration inside then you have
outside and this by itself this
concentration gradient as we'll see can
be used to fuel the production of atp by
atp synthase that those hydrogen ions
want to get back out they want to go
down their concentration gradient and as
they go back out through the atp
synthase it essentially turns that motor
that can jam the phosphate group onto
adp to produce atp
so one way to think about it this is
producing a
a hydrogen ion gradient so we could do
it this way we could say h plus
gradient
which is b then being used to produce
the actual atp
now the electrons going from a high
energy state to a lower energy state in
this part of the light dependent
reactions that by itself isn't the only
thing that is contributing to the
hydrogen ion concentration gradient
once that electron gets donated you
might say well how does it get replaced
well the thing that's doing the donating
the thing that eventually gets excited
and donates that electron it's a
chlorophyll
a variation called p680
p680 is referring to the p stands for
pigment 680 stands for 680 nanometers
the wavelength of light that it absorbs
best and so when it gets excited it
becomes you'll see the notation often of
p680
star that's when it has an excited
electron and then after it gives away
its electron it becomes p
it becomes p680
p680
with a positive charge and this p680 we
could call it p680 plus right over here
or maybe a p680 ion this is actually a
very strong oxidizing agent it one of
the strongest if not the strongest we
know in biological systems and so it
really likes to grab electrons from
other things
and the thing that is around that it can
grab electrons from is actually water
and so this is such a strong oxidizing
agent that it can essentially oxidize
the oxygen in water and oxygen as itself
i mean oxidizing is named after oxygen
because oxygen is such a strong it's so
electronegative it's such a strong uh
it's it's the thing that's normally
doing the oxidizing so anyway it grabs
its electrons once it gets this p680
plus grabs an electron from water and
then the water essentially falls apart
so you're left just with the oxygen and
then the hydrogen ions and so those
hydrogen ions also contribute those
hydrogen ions also contribute to the
increased hydrogen ion concentration on
the inside and this is where we get this
is where we get the oxygen byproduct
right over here here we have one half of
an o2 so if you do this twice you're
going to have a molecular oxygen
so so far i've we've talked about how
the oxygen gets produced we've talked
about how the atp gets produced what
about the nadph
well we started our process in
photosystem 2 you might say why is it
called photosystem 2 if that's where we
start well it's actually that's because
that's the second photosystem to be
discovered you might say what is a
photosystem well these photosystems and
complexes they're combinations of
proteins and molecules and photosystem
in particular has chlorophyll and
variations of chlorophyll and pigment
molecules that are responsive to light
that are very easy that have electrons
that can get excited by light and they
can transfer that energy back down to
the p680 chlorophyll a pair which then
can have its excited its electron
excited and then it can give that to an
acceptor molecule and then it can go to
lower lower energy states and
pump that those hydrogen ions out
but that's not the entire light
dependent reactions that electron can
eventually make its way over to
photosystem one and why is it called
photosystem one well it's because the
first one that one that was discovered
in photosystem one there's another
chlorophyll a pair called p700 and
that's because it optimally absorbs what
light of a wavelength of 700 nanometers
and you have something similar that
happens that light can either directly
or indirectly excite its electron and
then that electron as it goes to a lower
energy level it goes from one molecule
to another it can be used to reduce nad
plus
into
nadph and so that's where the
nadph comes from and then once again
once the p700 has given its electron it
wants an electron and well it can get
that from the electron that one that's
been going from lower to lower and lower
energy states that's essentially been
making its way from you can
conceptualize it as the electron that's
been making its way from photosystem two
and so that's why you'll often see these
diagrams lights come in electron gets
energized it gets excited it goes to
lower and lower energy states as it's
doing that it's being transferred from
one molecule to another being
facilitated by enzymes that that energy
part of that energy is being used to
transfer hydrogen ions into
the thylakoid lumen into the interior
then it then
in photosystem one you have another
excitation event what that thing that
got excited can grab that electron that
went to lower lower energy states and
its excited electron can once again be
transferred from one molecule to another
in order to fuel or enter or provide the
energy for nadp plus being converted
into nadph and once again the whole idea
of the hydrogen ion concentration
increasing here can fuel atp synthase
which allows us to jam a phosphate onto
adp to produce atp so that is where we
actually get all of these things and the
by-product of course is our oxygen
and if you wanted to see
that same idea but kind of just thinking
from an energetic point of view without
all the complexity of seeing the the
physical components involved you see it
right over here where you have light
energy comes excites the electrons
when it when once the p680 has given
that electron away it wants an electron
really badly it gets it from the water
and then as that electron goes to lower
and lower lower energy states it can
eventually be grabbed by p 700 that has
given away it's an electron
and then it and then that electron that
that was excited at p 700 by once again
more light energy that can be
transferred from one molecule to another
to fuel the creation of nadph and this
part right over here this part this
phase right over here
as the energy goes from a high energy
state to as the electron goes from a
higher energy state to a lower energy
state fuels the pumping of hydrogen
protons into
into the actual thylakoid